- I think we are live.
So welcome everybody.
I'm thrilled to be here,
with my dear friend, Shelly and Gary.
And so I bet everybody's
asking about why are we here?
Why is capitalize on you so important?
I believe money is power.
And I've always said that to both of you,
but unfortunately women abdicate
control over the pocketbook
and that's time to change.
My personal mission is on equality,
and equality across race,
gender, age ability,
and capital is a factor.
And so if we're going to change it
and we're going to reach a quality,
we've got to reach it by educating
on how you can capitalize on you.
So-
- Hold on,
Hope, I thought we were here to create
one of the most successful podcasts
in the history of podcasts.
I might've gotten the wrong invite.
I mean, all those things
are marvelous and true.
I just wanted to make sure I
was in the right livestream
and the right podcast.
Like, can I still stay here?
Because that is a huge agenda of mine.
The single most impactful podcast
in the history of podcast.
- Well Gary, I was going
to jump in and say,
cause this is a big problem
because there's two taboo words for women;
money and power.
So am I on the right show?
Cause here I am the chicken,
why don't we see women on the dollar bill,
on the one, the ten, the twenty?
Let's go to a hundred.
I mean, what is wrong with this picture?
So Hope thanks for setting the context.
- Actually real quick,
just to like completely
take that with this show,
because I'm really excited about this
and everybody I'm Gary Vaynerchuk.
I'm unbelievably humbled,
to be with these two incredible women
talking about something I think
needs a lot more attention,
actually for pure fun,
because I think what is
great about this show,
is we are going to go deep.
And for everybody who's listening like,
this is really going
to get into value land.
And I kind of,
I'm excited about this being
more state than sizzle,
but real quick just for super fun,
Shelly, I'll start with you
and Hope I'll give you the
extra few seconds to think.
Who would you put on which dollar?
Like if we were like fully in
charge, we got a weird email.
You three are in charge of putting
the first woman on American currency,
Shelly who would you put
on and on which bill?
- Okay, well, so thank you for
asking that question because
we actually worked with the treasury,
the secretary of treasury
on putting a woman on the bill
and the Obama administration.
And it was going to be Harriet Tubman,
on the front of the 10.
And why the 10?
The 10, because the 10 will be recreated,
for the a hundred year anniversary
of women's right to vote.
So it was a monumental moment
for women to put her
on the front of the 10.
The problem was Hamilton
is on the front of the 10.
So we were going to be relegated
to the back of the bill.
And so I don't believe
we belong in little JPEGs on the back.
We belong on the front,
and a guy can move over
for a little while for
us to take the front.
We were going to be pushed to the 20.
The 20 is the bill that
is an ATM machines,
since the most popular bill.
But I think now that has
been delayed once again
with this administration.
So Harriet Tubman
- I love that.
- Hope?
Okay, so I'm going to start
from a totally different angle.
I wrote my college essay
about queen Elizabeth I,
as this absolute, you know, woman leader.
We don't have that.
We haven't had that and
let's just hope we do soon.
And so I would have actually always gone
for the the woman queen.
We don't have that,
but on the other side of my life,
is fighting for the unsung.
All the women you don't know.
I joke and I say about the
women of hidden figures.
They did the work, before
the movie came out.
Okay. Those are people that
I also want on every bill.
And we've got to get women
into the role of power
into the monetary role
of power and recognition.
But so I would start them.
I start them on the one,
because that's the bill
that's used the most.
I think it's going out of style.
I think currency by the
way is going out of style.
We can have another
conversation about that.
- We have a lot of
episodes to get into that.
- Exactly. But-
- Gary who would you put?
- I was thinking about
as you were talking,
I was like are we going
to move to the next thing
or are one of two of you going to ask?
You know, I think in a
lot of different terms,
like Rosa Parks was the name
I was thinking a lot about,
because it kind of mixes the
two answers you guys gave.
And that's where I think
I play a little bit,
meaning I like where you went Hope,
because I think in general,
I'm very similar.
Like I think a lot about my life and like,
why do I do operations?
I have all this leverage,
I'm in the prime of my career.
And like the silliest thing I actually do,
is actually run the business that I run,
from the standpoint of,
there's a lot of other people
that are incredible at operations.
And what I, you know,
was luckily in the DNA game given,
that's a harder rarer trait.
But I just enjoy the operations part.
It's the unsung part of me,
that I've operated businesses.
It's why I wanted to do this
when I was talking to you two.
Cause I think this show's going
to deal with a lot of practicality.
I think practicality is very underrated.
And I think what Rosa Parks did,
was just a very practical real life thing.
She wasn't a queen, which is amazing.
And, and obviously that was
a very progressive queen.
She was just a normal
human being living her life
and was just at a place where like,
hey, I don't think this makes sense.
Which very speaks to my heart,
because basically I just navigate life
trying to figure out what does
and doesn't make sense to me,
and it bodes well.
So I think, you know,
the $5 bill,
five is my favorite number.
That's why I always put up the
photo with my hand like this,
since I take so many selfies.
Five is the number of
the on the jets jersey
that my mom sewed to me.
So I would put on the $5 bill
and I would go with Rosa
Parks because I think,
a very simple act that
I'm sure it was done
many many other times
by people that were
suppressed during that time.
That was the right moment
that caught the consciousness.
And here we are,
just think about the nature of it,
a regular human being did something again,
that I think happened many other...
I don't think she was the
first black woman or black male
that said I'm not moving.
It's just the one.
It's the one that's sat.
And I liked that.
It speaks to my underdog nature.
It definitely speaks to what I think,
Hope is very right on, which is,
there's an ungodly amount
of people doing it today.
And so that's why I would go
with Rosa Parks on the five.
- But you know it's interesting
when you talk about ,
how much you love the operational side.
Because you're not someone
that sits still for very long
and you are very non-operational.
You're always creating your own rules,
which is why I think you
also love Rosa Parks.
Because she was a nonconformist.
- Yeah and I'm practical
after you break the system.
And I think that's a very...
- Exactly.
- That's a really nice segue
to what I think we're doing here,
and I'll let Hope
continue to take the lead.
You know obviously,
you know, I'm the guy hosted here.
But like for me, what is so powerful is,
practicality is underrated.
And I think on this subject matter,
this is what has always attracted me,
to Hope's message around
this through the last decade
is the practicality of the
relationship of money and women,
is fascinating to me and
sits in that place of like,
what's happening in the subconscious.
This is why I love branding, right?
We talk about subconscious
bias and the political things.
But I think about
subconscious decision making,
it's what I do well in marketing.
And I think like what I
hope this is, is a seed.
My great dream of this,
is that there's somebody
that's listening to this,
maybe the third episode, you know,
and she, or he for that matter
is just driving along or
running on a treadmill.
And this series becomes the
seed to that person's life work.
And that person becomes the person
that operationalizes a massive change.
And by the way, my hope
is that there's 13 people,
not just one.
So, you know for me, you're right.
I only look to break systems
but what makes me not a pontificator,
or somebody that just
lives on LinkedIn cursing
or even more noble versions of it,
a politician or a teacher or an author.
What makes me none of those things,
is my deep obsession with then
operating my hyperbole and thesis.
Like making it real life,
not just something I yell
about over a bourbon.
So that's kind of like...
I'm very excited about this endeavor.
I'm so honored to be on this with you two.
- Well Gary, the whole
thing is you walk the walk.
You always have,
you actually will go after me hard.
I'll go after you hard.
I like to say about my personal career.
I never thought of myself as a girl.
Okay. I thought of myself
as just one of the guys.
- A human.
- As a human, exactly.
And I think that, that's
the key and that's the grid
and all this conversation
about money and success.
Everybody thinks that it
has to be so formulaic
and learn here in this calculus class.
It's not, right?
Gary and Shelley,
like your pathway to
your financial success.
Gary, I know you personally joke
about how well you did academically.
- Yeah
(laughs)
- Right? I mean it wasn't
your math grades, right?
- Listen, I got the D in statistics
and I went on to build the largest
and fastest growing research
company in the world.
So it ain't in a textbook.
That's all I want to say.
And that's where mano a mano.
I mean, we completely go together.
I think it's about
experiences that trigger
you know, the success.
I hire for passion, train for skills.
So I've always followed my passion
and the money has followed,
versus going after this job
because I'm supposed to.
That just never felt right to me.
- I think one quick thing to
set up the show from day one,
this series, you know,
what I'm very aware of,
is that an outrageous amount of men
are going to listen to this.
I think we are going to
come through the filter
and the perspective and the angle,
of women's relationship with money.
Because I think it's a
very, very, very big gap.
But I'll be very frank
because I like to be,
I was actually...
(laughs)
I'm like excited to listen to Hope
and some of the guests too,
because like you know,
I'm an incredible earner
when it comes to business,
like I know how to make dollars.
But making your money work for
you is an absolute skill set.
And I think that they will
be touching on some of that.
So some of the people that
are listening, especially
I'm just gonna make some
assumptions from my audience land.
I think this is going to bring some really
financial education that I
would argue anybody can make.
And really the theme for me in life,
let alone this show is what
Hope said earlier which is,
I don't think of myself as guy, either.
I think of myself as a human,
which is what deploys
so much of my empathy.
I'm struggling to see my difference
between me and everybody else.
I still think I'm 18 when
I talk to 18 year olds.
And I think I'm 81 when
I talked to 81 year olds.
Boy, girl, black, brown,
or indifferent or white.
So I'm excited about the show,
keep setting up the context Hope because
we have an incredible guest,
and the three of us
can blab into like left field
for the rest of the show
and kind of not nail
what we want to do here.
- So Gary, it's about how to make money
how to, how to capitalize in your career
and multiply that money,
how to build your equity.
And I really want to say,
there are the water
cooler moments at advice
on investments and during COVID,
you've done a great job in
marketing for the now and Shelly,
you've done all these great programs
but we've got to build
these water cooler moments
and help you get that advice.
And that's one of the reasons I wanted,
I think doing this now, is
so fundamentally important.
Because it is, none of us in this screen,
look at each other as anything else,
but people who want to
move the needle forward
for all and in a productive,
lifelong learning way.
- Shelly, what's your two cents
on what made you sign up for
this or what you're excited
about this or how you
see this playing out?
- I think a lot of it is, you know,
for me in business,
I never really was given
my value or told, you know
you are going to be a rock
star and very successful.
I had to make my bed.
I had to find my way, create my path,
learn how to negotiate for myself,
believe in me because no one else did.
So I think, you know, it's lessons,
I think the best advice
comes from people who have
been there, down there,
and don't have the
perfect textbook example
of what making money growing
money and gaining power
and what kind of responsibility
you have with that power
to help the others you
know, rise to the rank.
So for me, as a woman in business,
it is very important
for women to understand
that it's not just about money
and power as we talked about,
but the capitalize on you,
how do you capitalize on
yourself, to continue to grow
and also love what you do?
Cause I think that that is
part of success and money.
- It's great
- Yeah.
I think it's bringing it all together.
I think it's giving it all together,
so that we can make a difference
that we can lift everybody up.
We talk about that.
We all, three of us talk about
that and now is the time.
And hopefully the world
will be a better place,
if we can accomplish it.
- One quick thing for everybody listening
post this recording,
we do have a live audience
watching on Facebook.
I am basically incapable
of not reading the comments
while I'm doing a show.
So I just want to do a fair warning
that I'll probably be
doing some interrupting
and random comments for people
that won't have any sense of it.
For example, I'm demanding
that my team here bans Clasher
in the comments who continues to put,
go bills.
I am very salty of the day
of this recording the Monday.
(laughs)
So I'm kidding.
Do not ban Clasher, but we will...
What I will try to do,
since I have a little practice in this,
we have incredible guests.
I think we're aiming for two.
We want to do the first episode,
with only one just because
we wanted to set the tone.
But the series will have
two guests per episode
is kind of our ambition.
I'm correct in that right Hope, Shelly?
- Yeah
- And I will also try to
play the role of interjecting
with the people from Facebook
or trying to lives, which
is where this is being aired
who are maybe adding 2 cents.
And maybe I'll incorporate
into some of my questions
and or for Hope or Shelly.
So I will establish that.
I'm really excited about this.
How many, what do we say?
We're doing this like everything I do.
(laughs)
I can't speak for the other two ladies.
or we're doing a certain amount of them,
we'll take it to where the wind does.
But how many are we
locked in for four or six?
What did we end up doing?
I think we're saying six
but I mean, I think what
your point Gary as well,
we came up with a name
by polling everybody.
We actually want other people...
What do you want as advice as well?
We have the shows lined up.
We believe in being flexible
and answering some of the
needs that are out there.
Because no road is perfect.
- Well, I think that the
reason the three of us
came together is anything goes.
I think we've created our
success in very different ways.
Very non-linear paths,
Hope's was a little more
linear, but very non-linear.
And I think that is the best advice.
So we also want people to
be sending in questions.
Ask us anything.
And we will, you know, give
you to the best of our ability,
you know, real life stories
and real life examples,
including the guests that we're
bringing in to share them.
So I think that's what's
so important about this.
Ask us anything and anything goes.
- No old card,
and anybody who knows any
one of the three of us,
knows that we will ask
each other tough questions,
and we will answer them authentically
because that's what matters.
That's what helps the discussion.
And again, going back
to my view on women and girls and money,
they didn't, they didn't ask,
they didn't ask the question
and because they were afraid.
And we got to stop that.
There's no such thing as a bad question.
- Well I think-
- We have to stop that fear.
- You gave great advice when I said,
you know, there is a whole
concept of best advice
for how to invest your
money pre COVID days.
And then you said, and what
people are thinking about
is the different strategies during COVID.
And so I would love to hear from you,
we're just waiting for Mindy to join.
While we're waiting,
give us some great financial advice,
for how to invest differently
during this COVID moment.
- Well I mean, listen the first thing
I put up a couple of pieces on LinkedIn.
I think it's really important,
is you got to first count your bananas.
And I mean that Gary
and I talked about that
because it actually came from Gary.
Gary knew what every
cost in his office was,
every single company
I've ever invested in.
That's what we did first.
What, what do you have?
Because before you can talk
about investing, Shelly
what do you have?
What are your upcoming expenses?
And this is not calculus, right?
This is A plus B, right?
What A minus C ,
what do you have?
And then you can decide how to invest.
Because then what do you need?
When do you need that money, right?
Might you need that money?
Because if you need that money,
tying it up in a longer term strategy,
is not a good idea.
So it's about your liquidity
and it's about your tolerance for risk.
So I think the answer there
isn't one answer Shelly,
it's actually individual,
but first assess what you have,
assess what you need,
and assess whether you're
not going to need...
when you need to access that money,
anytime in the near future, right?
Private investments that can
yield you a lot of money,
are highly risky sometimes,
- Let's talk about that for
about hundredth of a second,
like highly risky, like
highly like everyone,
You know what happens?
We have these moments of time
when people become fascinated
about things and startup investing.
Everybody like the older set,
couldn't wait to find their
son or daughter's best friend,
that was going to be the
next Mark Zuckerberg.
Like we are a Hollywood,
storytelling, infatuated society.
The Social Network movie comes out,
and literally,
I mean like I took
thousands of these meetings
over the course of a decade,
regular businessmen and women
reached out to me because
I come from a regular business,
before I got into the
Silicon Valley stuff.
And like the smartest most
conservative guys and girls
I knew from the liquor business,
mainly guys would think things like,
Hey, I want to put a 100K into a startup.
Do you know any Mark Zuckerberg like that?
I'm like, do you understand
the math around Facebook?
Like 98% likelihood,
99% likelihood that you're
about to put a hundred,
especially at that time.
Like, I would argue
that post this pandemic,
if things get tighter,
like I am in really, I haven't
and Hope, you know this.
I haven't really invested in startups
the last three or four years.
And Oh, by the way, the ones I
have I've done extremely well
because it's back to what I did.
Three, like the first time with Facebook.
Facebook Tumblr, and Twitter for me were,
I believe in Evan Williams.
I believe in Mark Zuckerberg.
I believe in David Karp.
I believe in the traction
they already have.
Tens of millions of users
not, Oh, this person went to
a good college, seems smart.
And I subjectively like
this idea with no context,
do they have the stomach
to be an entrepreneur?
And that's what I went back to.
Like, I just had a very
large exit with Liquid IV,
Unilever just bought.
Like I knew want to invest
in Brandon's company.
It was just so obvious to me
that this kid was going to win.
Right. It's what happened
with me with Mick Mack.
I keep doubling down on Rachel Tipograph,
Like sometimes I just can't help
because it's so obvious
to me about the human.
But yeah, I mean,
for everybody's watching right now
investing like you know,
I just think that this this
is what I want to get into
because I know what Hope and
Shelley brings to the table.
And I think, what I'm going to be watching
and doing more listen
to the normal it's like,
when can I inject like now,
like right now the point is this,
no, it is not highly risky.
It is almost guaranteed
that you will lose money
if you invest in a startup.
- Correct.
- That is a big deal,
because I think most people think
it's like a 50, 50 crapshoot.
Like, no, no,
And you have to put 25 or 50
or a 100K in to even get in.
So it's not like buying
10 shares of Apple,
or like buying, like what,
I'm hot on a baseball card
that might go down or might go up.
You're locked in for 20 to 50 K
and you're locked in kind of forever.
Like, it's not liquid.
- Well, you can't sell it.
You can't go to the open
market and go sell it.
You go buy those 10 shares
of Apple and you can sell it.
If you need the money.
You go invest in a startup.
You can't, you have to
assume it's going to fail.
And it's, that's a really really-
- And on record, every dollar
I've ever put into a startup,
I have 100% written off in my head.
I don't need it to pay my
bills or to feed my family.
It is gone, period.
- So venture investing has to go,
in your highest risk category. Okay.
And only when you can absolutely afford
to lose every ounce of that.
And that's really important.
And Gary, there's one other
thing you're not at it.
You're not saying about what
you do about venture investing.
When you invest in a company,
you also give yourself to that company.
And by that you're helping
them get to success faster.
You're accelerating the growth.
- And I had to learn Hope,
that I wasn't to your point.
And that's why I did well early on.
Cause I was, but then as I got stretched,
then I realized and my financial
situation changed, you know
because I started over at 34
and didn't have a lot of money.
Like every dollar was like petrified.
And even though I wrote it off,
I really wanted it to win.
Whereas now, I realized, Ugh,
you know in this kind of like
mockery place three years ago,
four years ago,
which is why I changed my behavior.
I'm like, Ooh, I'm writing like a 100 K,
which means a lot to me.
I came from nothing,
but it's not enough to
make me go do something.
They're not reaching out to me.
I'm running their company.
And might to your point
might impact on it,
was far less than the early stuff.
And far less than the last three or four
that I got involved with.
You know, for say MikMak,
I went on the board
you know, like and it's
close to VaynerMedia
so I can send Rachel
clients and she's like me.
So I can tutor or mentor.
That's such a great point.
I have some level of impact
to your 0.99% dollars.
You're passive and it's not liquid.
And it's 99% likely to go away.
- But I think you also are talking about,
it's not just your investment.
You also are taking the interest.
Like when you have an
interest in the company
and in the people,
that's when you unlock your magic.
It's not just a passive investment
and then you watch.
- But Self-awareness,
one of the things that I
really want to talk about,
and I'm going to let you two take over.
It's like, and of course
we're talking generalizations.
So like, let there be no
confusion, every human's different.
But when we think about this show,
especially from the female lens,
you know I think one thing I
look for a lot is self esteem,
and self awareness, right?
And I do think that that is something
that everybody who's listening now
needs to think about to your point.
Like for me, what I realized is,
Oh right. When I see a scrappy kid,
it's why I unfairly razz,
you know, Ivy league kids.
They're just as likely to win,
it just it doesn't speak
to my soul the same way
cause it's not who I am.
to your point, Shelley it
took me time to realize
Oh, this is what I'm attracted to.
You know, the internet kids
that I was investing in 2005
and 2006, they were the underdogs.
- Right.
- A hundred percent
- They were nerds, wasn't
cool, nobody believed.
Now it's completely in the other chasm
which is why I've lost my spirit for it.
So for everybody's listening,
find where your spirit is,
because that's going to
allow you to go deeper.
- Hundred percent (indistinct)
hope that we're going
to bring him right now.
I would love to welcome Mindy Grossman,
who is the CEO of WW.
- Hi guys.
- Hey
It was like the perfect clue
when Gary was going on, Gary V,
about the people we believe in
and the people that can build
a business, drive a business
not just inherit one,
but create one based on
passion and power and money
and all of those things.
There is no one better
to reflect those values
than you Mindy.
We are so excited to have you here.
- Thank you.
And Gary, I love what you
just said about self esteem
and self awareness.
I always say, particularly to women,
self-awareness is your
greatest super power.
And it's just so important.
And that belief in yourself,
comes from extreme awareness.
- But Mindy, where did that
extreme awareness for you?
Was there a pivot moment?
Was there one of those
heartbeat moments that you had,
that said, you know, cause
you've risen the ranks,
you've won every accolade
of most powerful women
on fortune Forbes on,
you know, and everything.
Was there a moment in
your career that you found
that confidence kind of emanated from you?
You said I got this and I can do anything-
- You know I thinks it's been a journey.
I think it's been a journey
that's really built.
You know, I took a risk
very early in my career.
You know, I was supposed to be a lawyer.
I was supposed to get married.
And at the last minute
in my last semester of college
and I started college at 16.
I just decided to change my life.
And I moved to New York at 20, in 1977.
Broke my engagement, decided
not to go to law school
instead, I'm going to figure it out.
So I always say not taking the
risk would have been riskier.
So it definitely gave me the confidence
and a lot of what I did.
But when I moved to New York,
I had no finances.
I didn't have no parental support.
You know, they didn't
have the wherewithal.
And so it was really about
my taking care of myself.
And I would say,
that the one thing in the first few years,
that I didn't do enough of
was think about security.
It was you know, spend what you have.
And then as I got older
and I understood the business skills,
I said I'm not applying
my business skills,
to my personal life.
And I need to be as focused,
as educated and aware
as I am in business in
my personal finances.
And that was a big moment for me.
And then when I got married,
I'm married to a mathematical physicist
who is a financial expert. Right.
But I wasn't going to
abdicate my intentions,
my right and my understanding
of where I wanted to go with finances.
So we've been partners in
this journey the whole time.
And I think one of the
wake up calls for me
is I had a girlfriend,
who's very sadly her
husband all of a sudden
died on the racquetball court.
And she had no idea where anything was,
their finances, what their status was.
And I remember saying that
should happen to no one,
you know, you should be
the owner of what it is
your goals are and everything else.
Now that doesn't mean
you can't have a partner,
but you need to be as educated, informed,
you need to make the right decisions
whether they be about an investment,
or whether they be about
what you want to save
versus what you want to make
and Hope I was listening
to you as well earlier,
everything is individual.
Whether it's a level of risk,
or you know what you are comfortable with
and what your joint plans are.
And so throughout, you
know, our relationship,
even to this day,
we are both very involved
in whatever decisions
that we're making together.
And we certainly have our own individual
investment decisions.
And the other point you made
that I thought was really smart
is any startup investment I make,
I assume I'm going to get nothing back.
Now, I do it because I
believe in the people-
- And you might win
- Just like Gary believed in Rachel
You believe in the person and
you will lend your support.
So, you know, I made the decision
to start investing in some early stage
women founded businesses
and said I can give
them, you know, capital
but I can also give them support.
And so if it works great, and if not
I did my best to help
support the investment
- Mindy, real quick.
You played at the highest levels
of business in this world.
Do you think that financial literacy,
because the story you told
about the racquet ball
a gentlemen, which is devastating,
is such a common story.
For the women of the
50s, 60s, 70s, 80s, 90s.
You know, and I think there
has been a turn thank God.
But as you were talking, literally,
I was like how many of the guys,
that were at the racquetball
guys that died also,
had no like physical literacy.
Like when you think about physical,
like financial money
literacy across the board,
because you interact so
heavily across the board,
do you agree with my assumptions that like
in general people's
relationship with money
and even more so women
is just stunningly low.
- Absolutely. I think financial literacy
could be a prerequisite,
as much as you need ABCs.
- I agree.
- Right?
- So Mindy, shouldn't it be taught?
Shouldn't it be taught?
Like they used to teach,
they don't teach...
They basic...
And I don't even want to-
I don't like calling a financial literacy.
Because I think that scares people, right?
- It's a scary word.
- Can we call it,
know what to do with your fucking money?
(laughs)
(indistinct)
- You know, I didn't even have,
the certain other classes I need to take.
And I, you know, for example,
you know, when I really went into business
and started up the ranks
and really owning P & Ls,
I said, I really need
to be further educated.
And I went to take the executive
program at Harvard, right?
So why aren't we educating
ourselves about the business?
And we're not spending as
much time educating ourselves
about our financial future.
And you need to do both.
And I so agree it needs to be,
whatever you want to call the curricula.
It needs to be a prerequisite.
- And that's a whole thing.
So you went, you actually
took the initiative to go,
and lifelong learner go and
understand it better. Right?
You took that, but
we've got to help people
understand that they got to do it earlier.
If this is not calculus, right?
This is not complicated math, right?
You don't have to move from a
balance sheet to a cash flow,
- I always look around,
having that class would have done more
for most people than calculus.
- But I also-
- I got married to a mathematician.
So he gets a little upset when I say that.
- But I also think having
that class with contextual
real life experiences also helps a lot.
If you just read it in
isolation in a book,
would you really have
gained the same value
as having to live in
breathe managing cashflow
and liquidity and investment in that.
- And I do think that
particularly for women,
we need to educate ourselves
to have the confidence
to make the investment decisions.
And, you know, I'm sure you've
brought it up all the time.
We make 90% of the purchase decisions
and just a small percentage
of the investment decisions.
And women need to be better
advocates for themselves
and not abdicate their responsibility.
Because it's so critical.
You know, even if you're you're partnering
but let's say you're just building your...
What you need in your career
and what you want in your life,
setting those goals and having those plans
and understanding the risks
that you're open to taking
and what investment decisions
at some point do you need
to start thinking about,
that's education.
- So Mindy, I couldn't agree.
You also talked about coming
out and in from college.
Nope. I too, didn't get married
the first time so to speak,
I walked away and you have
to own it yourself. Right?
And that sends you and
Gary you talk often about-
- Can I ask Hope, I'm
sorry to interrupt you.
The fact that you and Mindy
have this shared experience,
is, you know really-
- Even I do by the way.
- You too Shell?
- Yeah.
- This is just really interesting to me,
because I think all the good for me
has been under social studies and history.
Very simple question.
Was that commonly happening
for strong women in your generation?
Like, was that like something that
you know, you and your other A...
I mean, look at the three of
you of what ended up happening.
You see that behavior happening,
was that happening
quite a bit at that time
or, and, or, and, or, and,
did a lot of people end up
going into those marriages
and then get into the divorces
or just live those unhappy lives.
Cause they were the alpha
and that was what you were supposed to do.
And supposed that you had enough yous
and a lot of women made that decision.
Because people were getting
married so much younger.
Also in that era,
I'm very curious from a
social study standpoint
because it might even
help one listener today
going through it.
- Yeah, I think for me,
you know I was adopted,
and you know I was always told
that I'd been given this gift.
So I took it very seriously.
So, I definitely rushed to get
through, to prove something
because I wanted to be able
to then use that gift. Right.
So I was very serious
and I thought I had to
be on a certain timeline.
And that's when I really
had the revelation
that it's not a timeline.
It has to be right.
And you have to be passionate.
You have to be purposeful,
you have to be fulfilled.
And that is ultimately
what's going to allow you to have impact.
And, you know, I finally got married,
you know 9 years after that.
But I think sometimes
first you need the time,
to get that self awareness
of what you really need.
- Yeah.
- And I admit
Yeah Mindy, I completely agree.
But the difference for me,
I was working in investment banking
and I was working crazy hours.
And I was sort of told, you can't do that.
And I'm like, I can't do that?
Like is-
- You mean get married ?
Or you can't do investment banking?
- I can't live the crazy business life
and be married and have kids.
And I'm like, are you kidding?
You mean, you want me
barefoot in the kitchen?
(laughs)
It was definitely that you've
got the wrong person here,
and you know, I'm going to make it for me.
Okay. I'm not going to
make it as Mrs. So, and So.
- Yeah, myself as well, totally
- I was going for an MRS degree.
That was for sure,
I never thought that I was going
to be the CEO of a company.
And it was only until I found my stride
of who I was as a whole person,
who I was in business
and who I wanted to be as a parent,
that I was able to you know,
become my best self,
not fall in to it.
Cause I don't think I ever would have
ended up in the workplace.
If I married the person
I was going to marry,
I would have been the
supportive person on the-
- I think Gary, we're all
three saying the same thing.
It's also about self-reliance ultimately,
we want it to be the one
dictating the pathway.
We wanted to be the one owning it.
You know, this whole series to me,
is about getting everybody
else to stand up,
capitalize on yourself
and have the confidence that you can do.
Let's give you the tools.
Let's help you,
because that's ultimately how
it change in a quality happen.
- Yeah. And it goes back
to what Shelly said.
It goes back to self-belief, right.
And confidence and the
ability to truly believe
that you're deserving and capable. Right?
And you have to though believe it first.
And I think that's, we're all
saying something very similar.
- Well, I think confidence
starts at the age of five.
And so when Gary was
talking about, you know
the learning in school,
you know, even at a young ,
knowing your value and your worth.
That boys and girls are worth the same
and they bring different
skills to the table
and that's very powerful.
Back to capitalize on you.
I just wanted to ask you Mindy,
you know, from compensation,
when you went for the big job
and had to negotiate for yourself,
you know cause you can have lawyers
and you can have all that.
But at the end of the day,
you got to believe in you
and know what your value is.
Where did that come from?
How did you do that first negotiation
that took you to new place?
- I would say that that first negotiation
or the first range of negotiations
were very uncomfortable.
And I just kept saying to myself,
it's okay to be uncomfortable
but you need to advocate for yourself.
And I just remember there
was one negotiation,
and at the last minute I
almost acquiesced to something
and my husband looked at me and
said a man wouldn't do that.
And was like, somebody
slapped me in the face
and it's because I wanted it. Right.
And I stepped back and I said, you know,
every once in a while you need the people
that can tell you the truth.
And you have to know your worth. Right?
It's not just because you want something,
what truly is your worth
and you need to advocate for your worth.
So, you know, I've always
done a lot of homework.
And yes, I've had lawyers
and yes I've had advisors
but I've done the homework
on what I think I'm worth
and what I think I can
contribute to the business.
And if someone doesn't believe in that,
then maybe I don't belong there.
- Yeah. Honestly, for
everybody's listening because,
you know, for example, I don't know...
I actually, my dad always makes fun of me
because I prefer to negotiate in a manner
that leaves a little bit more
on the other side of the
table than for myself,
it is my state.
It is what I'm more most comfortable with.
And I've never associated that.
I associate a lot of my things through
the years as I grew up,
because my mom is my hero.
With my feminine side or my
soft skills or what I eat.
Even things that are not women versus men
like empathy and sympathy.
We've categorized those things,
but I've always understood.
But I never thought about my
negotiation style as that,
but I hear so much more
about know your worth.
And you know,
in the female conversation
sector that I spend time in.
But I think everybody
probably understands this,
but I think it's important.
It's like creative,
you know, we've talked
about this Mindy and Shelley
and other business contexts like creative,
it's subjective.
One of my favorite female
juggernaut scaled Tifford
who you work with Mindy.
Like even when she was at Unilever.
And by the way we said WW,
for like a lot of people don't know,
that is like the rebrand
of Weight Watchers
just to give context
for everybody listening.
So, you know, when you go through rebrand,
I always like to do that.
Just so everybody knows what's going on.
You know, knowing your worth
is actually subjective.
You know, and could be-
- Well, it depends.
- You just took words out of my mouth.
- You have-
- Go ahead, go ahead.
- You have to look at the business,
- Correct.
- You have to look
at where the business is,
what you think you can
contribute to the business.
And what do you think that
impact is going to be?
And anyone who's looked at kind of,
I've been running public
companies so everything is public.
I build whatever that compensation is,
bidding on the impact I
can make on the company.
And if I can make the impact
I will be compensated commensurately.
And I in particular always
chosen growth and transformation.
So it's a different kind of role-
- 100% having empathy and
understanding to the audience.
99.9% of the people here,
are definitely not going
to run a public company.
And then 95% of the people here
are going to work in private environments
where they're not going
to have very clean data
around the comps.
But for example, if you're
a minority or woman,
or if you're a man white
man, everybody asking
and putting pressure on HR or the owner
or whatever around comps,
you know, I come from
family business land.
The last two coaching-ups I've done,
have been for two people
trying to negotiate with a
father and one with the father,
one with a mother owner,
where the kids are getting paid 400,000
to be losers in the building.
And they're driving the business at 120.
And they're trying to
figure out what to do,
that takes negotiating
with Sasha Vaynerchuk
in that scenario.
Very different than negotiating
with the HR company at WW or Vayner,
very different than if you're joining
Shelley's female private...
Like there's so many variables.
I think where I'm trying to go
is don't beat yourself up
if you've signed on a deal.
And you're like, knowing
if you got your worth,
can be very daunting I've noticed.
From my perspective,
but to your point Mindy,
conceding for something you
do not want to concede for,
you have to understand,
saying no for yourself in that
negotiation makes no sense.
At least put it on the table,
let them say no a third time.
- I could not agree.
And the other thing is,
and I absolutely hear what you're saying.
And again, I think you do different things
at different points in your career.
And if you have made the decision, right?
and you've left whatever it
is cause you can't quantify.
When you start and you
are having an impact,
and you have quantitative
measures of your success
on the business,
don't be afraid to advocate for yourself.
And at some point,
go back and have another conversation.
- Sorry, hope you said
something very important
which was the quantifiable piece.
And then you also bet on
the upside on yourself.
So you did your compensation negotiation
with equity and with cash,
but where you put the big win,
was in what you were going to deliver
because you believe in you
and you can quantify that
performance and success.
- And Mindy, and Shelly,
that's exactly what I was going to add.
At some point, there's a
transition from dollar salary comp,
to equity at betting on
yourself for the future.
And you have to have the confidence,
because that's where you build
up really longterm capital.
Especially if you help build the business
and you have the belief
in yourself, your team
and everybody around that.
Make that bet
everybody can't at every
point of their lifestyle.
But we're going to have
conversations on this show,
about when you switch and
when you step on the gas,
with equity compensation versus cash.
- Right, and it really depends,
on where you are in your financial status,
what risk you want to take.
You know, if you don't have a home yet
you want to build investment for that.
You're going to make different decisions,
on where that balance is going to be.
So it's not a one size fits all.
Everybody's really individual.
- Can I open up the forum for a second?
I want all three of you to speak to this.
Cynthia says,
this is not speaking to
the women, who has...
this is how she write.
Who has no time to
waste, no money to waste
and needs exact step-by-steps.
So for five to 10 minutes, wrapping here,
all three of you please chime in.
You know, what do we say to Cynthia?
Who leaves that comment right
now on Facebook live of late.
What is kind of some step-by-step 101s,
for someone who's concerned about time,
concerned about having to any,
or just maybe just a tiny
bit of money working for her,
thoughts on some scenarios you've seen
and maybe some practical
tips of starting points.
- I'm going to start by, Cynthia
I wrote a piece on the return on time.
I said, I got taught on
the return on investment
from a very young age because
I've been in finance my whole life.
But nobody talks to women
about the return on time.
And I think it's really, really important.
You don't have a lot of time
and COVID has probably made you realize-
- Hope, back to time
since they're probably not
going to go to your LinkedIn,
though I recommend everyone should,
cause Hope is on fire and read it.
Just some quick, rapid like,
are we talking about stuff
that I get passionate about,
which is like audit your 7:00 PM to 12...
If you're not happy or you're
concerned you're anxious,
but you're also watching
entire seasons of content on Netflix.
That's a debatable time,
because I talk to people
in really shitty situations
about time,
because I have a lot of
friends in shitty situations
and I have a large social footprint.
and I will go there for 25
minutes with one person,
because then I want the rep
and I want to bring value.
Even the ones that are in the most
I don't have time,
when you really go there.
I understand you have three kids
one job, single parent,
you really go there.
You get into this incredible
debate of one's need,
for a little bit of
escapism on a Tuesday night
when they're fried.
And they're the
opportunity to do something
with that hour and a half at night.
That may get you out of the hamster wheel.
How do you think about that
Hope from your perspective?
- Well, so it goes back to Mindy,
who went and took this Harvard class,
right now not everybody's going
to take that Harvard class.
There is plenty of material online,
to get a little bit of
financial education.
And one of the things that
I am desperately hoping
that this is going to do as
we roll out these guests,
is give you in short
snippets, really good advice
on how to learn about investing,
risk, HR, asking for more.
And so the little things
you can do every day,
even if you take 15 minutes
Gary, you actually joked
with me about exercise
about this right?
You know, you gotta get
your head in the game
and you know, give 15 minutes extras.
How do we take 15 minutes a day to learn?
- Hope, Hope, I don't have time,
is the great excuse of
people that don't want to do.
It is also the sheer reality
to a very small percent of people
that have had incredible
adversity in their lives.
They're both can be true,
but I speak a lot of times to the 94%.
Because the 6% need a totally
different piece of content.
Let there be no confusion.
I don't have time is one of
the easiest things to audit
when somebody is completely full of shit.
What they're saying oftentimes is,
I'm not motivated to do
something I don't enjoy.
It goes back to self-awareness.
All of us really got hot on that because-
- But you also have to think of this,
as another form of self-care.
Your financial security is self-care.
So I think assessing
and having a deep knowledge
of where you are at the moment
and then setting a goal that's definable.
And when I say realistic, you know,
I find that with too many people do
as they go to set a goal
and it's like something-
- I'm going to be Beyonce and create
a billion dollar make up-
- So I think step goals,
steps along the way.
So you at least feel that
you've accomplished something
when you hit that first.
And it doesn't have to be big.
Maybe it's just a change in behavior.
Maybe it's just a shift in focused.
You know, it could be any of those things,
but I am an obsessive list maker.
I always have been.
Whether it's, you know, what do I see?
What do I want in my next career move?
You know, what do I want in my life?
And I find it very, very helpful.
Because I have something
I can really refer to,
when I can be distracted.
It keeps one focused on what
really the priorities are,
and that's where you
need to take the time.
And that's what I mean
by the form of self care.
- And I think time is money
and you need to prioritize.
So you need to focus
cause you can't do it,
all every day all the time.
You have one life with five dimensions.
You have your career, you have your family
you have your community,
you have your friends
and the fifth is yourself.
And you can't forget about that bucket.
And you know, I have a no regret policy.
I always look forward and
I never want to look back
and say Shelly would have gone-
So I think forward and act in the moment.
Every day is a new day, with choices.
Time is choice.
How do you want to spend your time?
and be thoughtful.
And you can't do all five
dimensions all the time.
It's based on your life
stages and where you are.
So pick and choose where
your priorities are
where your focus are
and then allocate your time accordingly.
So you never use excuses
that you don't have time.
We all have...
- Where you lay self-awareness
cause Mindy's point is so important.
It's such please, everybody listen,
when you make a goal that
is what you wish you were
versus what you are.
You are in deep shit.
I always push people.
Like, I mean I went through
this with my sister,
who's the best, Liz Novello big shout out.
Finally as happy as I've ever seen her.
Why? through a lot of conversations
with her older brother
who loves this shit
and she has full access to me,
she had to go through a process
of she's not going to...
She loves teaching,
but she did it because it was the safest.
She is so happy to and loves her kids
and is the best mother,
but she's not going to be
the mother that we had,
who wanted more than
breathing to stay home
and see every second.
She's too alpha.
She had to go back to being
16 and selling baby clothes,
in a baby outlet store, to remind herself
that she loves selling
like her older brother.
And now that she does real
estate and she does it
in balance with being
a mother, she's shining
but she had to figure out
and she was driven by money.
Let there be no, like let
this be on the record.
My sister and dad are far more.
And my grandmother
that's the lineage of
the DNA of that family.
They are much more driven by money.
And what I tried to
explain to her is like,
look, my passion led to
something that did money,
but I could have very easily
if the DNA was different.
If my passion was art,
I might've done something
that did not make me as much money.
Cause I'm in it for the game.
You my sister, you're in it for the money.
Take a step back, be self aware.
And real estate is a game
this is back to the question of like,
what's the step by step,
Step one,
What's the most likely
fucking thing you can do
that will give you money.
You, you, the human are you a worker bee.
Are you an admin for a list superstar?
Are you good at buying stuff
at garage sales and thrift
stores and flipping it,
should you start a honey company.
Like you, what are you
best that to make money?
That starting point one,
because you're not saving and investing
becomes completely irrelevant
if you don't make enough
to sustain a roof over your head and eat.
And have something left over.
And Oh by the way, roof
over your head and eat
doesn't mean BMW and Prado bags
and all the fucking bullshit
all of your wasting money on,
which leaves you with no money.
Because you're using those
things as oftentimes band-aids
for insecurity because you
want to look successful
instead of being successful.
(indistinct)
- Mindy your lists.
When you said you're a list taker.
I always say don't do a to do list,
but have it to be list of really you know,
what matters to you most?
Sorry, go ahead.
- Yeah. Well actually the other thing,
is have a not to do list.
So I think the prioritization
what I call ultimate
discretion is really important
especially in the beginning,
what is truly a need.
And then when you want an indulgence,
have it be purposeful right?
And you know, I've gone
through those processes.
And you know, I think that
your over the course of time
compared to, you know when I
was my very younger self Gary,
when I just wanted you know, stuff.
I was working, I was making money.
I'm completely opposite now,
where I'm very purposeful
about those things that are
going to be important in my life.
And you know, and that's what
when I talk to younger
women or younger people
I said, the earlier you
can start doing that.
The more fulfilled you will actually be
because the things you choose to do,
are going to be that much
more meaningful to you.
- Well, CEO WW can you purposely
save the last three points
for something yummy.
- Exactly.
- Hope we got to wrap.
You want to wrap?
(laughs)
- So, you know, listen,
first of all, this has been great.
And I believe Mindy, I couldn't
agree more about purpose,
Gary and I met on a nonprofit board.
It's all, you know,
it's not about buying for yourself.
It's about being a giver.
So I think that's an
unbelievable way to close.
And I also think it's about systems.
It's about reaching out to other people.
The today's world of social media.
We're all on it.
We're all available.
Reach out if you need help,
if you need help, reach out,
ask for a specific thing,
find your sponsors.
This is the beginning of a conversation
that is so unbelievably important to me.
I think to all of us here,
it's about capitalizing on you
and all the toolkits we
can give you for success.
You know, I like to say, you know,
what's the lesson to your younger self.
And so Mindy let's leave with,
what's lessons in your younger
self and Gary and Shelley
for the audience.
- Yeah. I would say be
the master of yourself.
And it's kind of what is
going to be important to you,
but determine that early
and be very strategic,
thoughtful and purposeful
about what you decide to do.
But it's also about belief
that comes from education and knowledge
and knowing when is the
right time to take a risk.
- Shell?
- I'd say capitalize on you.
I mean, I think that, it's be yourself
because everyone else
has taken us for a while.
It says the best Gary V.
- I'm going to go a
little bit narrow here.
I think that I grew up in
a very immigrant household
where I'm going to talk to a
different group of people here
where saving money was everything.
Like there would just was nothing else.
And I've watched my
dad navigate that life.
And you know, I had a lot
of those tendencies too.
I think you know,
money in the bank doesn't
give the interest rates
that they used to and money in general.
Like, so for a small group,
because I've spent a lot
of my energy here with the
people that don't have it,
but like having $13,000, you
know $28,000 and say like...
If I'm talking to my younger self,
I did a really good job because
I saved, I saved, I saved.
Then I deployed very high risks.
I thought I had a lot of
earning in front of me
and I invested in Facebook,
Twitter and tumbler.
And I changed the course of my life.
That was much better.
And then by the way,
my famous passing on Uber twice happened
because I overextended myself a little bit
on an apartment in New York city.
And I valued having some
cash a little too much
and passed on something that
was very intuitive to me,
which would have...
I mean, that was a $500 million mistake.
There's no other way to say it,
real life math back to the data.
And so like thinking
about my younger self,
my advice it's you know,
maybe have your cash
savings be even smaller
than you think you needed.
And being thoughtful about where
you invested those dollars.
So I think a little more offense
because the romance for me
off of that first generation immigration
and I think a lot of people can think
of their grandparents the way I'm talking
because those were the
people that first over-
I think there is some
offense DNA for younger me
who had a lot of,
there's a lot of people right
now who do have the ability
and believe in themselves
to earn for a long time.
And, and if that's the case,
you should be thoughtful
about how you invest
and have a mix of smart investing
and probably some high risk.
Because cash and bank
surely gets really less sexy
for somebody that was like
me and I over valued it.
A lot of parts of my career.
So that's, the specific narrow one to me.
- Cash under the mattress
doesn't go very far either.
- Yeah now, that also still means
like I will go to the grave
with a certain number.
That's my personal number
of like true like Armageddon
and like take the cash and run.
So I, I still have that.
- But the bottom line is we all need,
we all need to learn.
We all need to figure
out what works for us.
What kind of financial situation,
how hungry are we,
everybody's different.
I want to get the tools out there,
so that we all can be successful
to that we can build money.
And for those that don't have,
and don't have the time,
how help them find the resources to get
out of the hole to pay
down debt, et cetera.
Talk to you about debt.
Talk to you about interest rates.
We're going to do that
all on these coming shows.
But the bottom line is, we
truly believe that building
and capitalizing on you
can make a huge difference in the future.
And that's why we're all here.
Mindy. Thank you.
You know, you are,
it was absolutely great.
- No I think what you are
doing is just so important.
And it's going to be such a valuable asset
to so many more now than ever.
- Thank you.
And you were our first guest.
You've just opened up
- I'm so honored.
- There's so many more.
Thank you everyone.
- Thanks everyone for making a difference.
- Bye everyone. Good luck.
- Thank you.
- Thanks Mindy.
- Thanks Mindy
- Great job everyone.